so
maybe to dig more technically on the
question of intelligence
do you think it's difficult for
intelligent life to arise
like it did on earth from everything
you've written and studied about the
brain
how magical of a thing is it
in terms of the odds it takes to arise
yeah so you know magic is just
don't get me wrong i mean i i like them
i like a magic shirt as much as the next
person
my husband was a magician at one time
but
you know magic is just a bunch of stuff
that we don't really understand how it
works yet so
i would say from what i understand there
are some major steps
in the course of evolution that
at the beginning of life the step from
single cell to multicellular organisms
things like that which are
really not known i think for me the
question is not so much um
could it you know what's the likelihood
that it would happen again
as much as um
what are the steps and how long would it
take and if it were to happen again on
earth
would would we end up with the same
you know menu of life forms that we
currently have now and i think the
answer is probably no
right there's just so much about
evolution that is stochastic and
driven by chance but the question is
whether that menu would be equally
delicious
meaning like there'd be rich complexity
of the kind of
like would we get dolphins and humans or
whoever else falls in that category of
weirdly intelligent
seemingly intelligent however we define
that
well i think that has to be true if you
just look at the range of creatures
who've gone extinct
i mean but if you look at the range of
creatures that
are on the earth now it's incredible
and you know it's sort of tried to say
that but it actually is really
incredible
um particularly i don't know i mean
animals there are animals that seem
really ordinary
until you watch them closely and then
they become miraculous you know like
certain types of birds which do very
miraculous things
uh um build you know
bowers and do dances and all these
really funky things that
are hard to explain uh with a standard
evolutionary story although
you know um people have them birds are
weird they do a lot of
for mating purposes they they have a
concept of beauty
i haven't quite maybe you know much
better but it doesn't seem to fit
evolutionary arguments well it does fit
it well it depends right so i think
you're talking about the evolution of
beauty
the um book that was written recently by
was it from um without his name richard
frum i think
yeah no i didn't oh it's a great book
it's very controversial though because
he is argues make an argument that
the question about birds and some other
animals is why would they
engage in such metabolically costly
displays when it doesn't improve their
fitness at all
and the answer that he gives is the
answer that darwin gave
which is sexual selection um not natural
selection but you know
selection can occur for all kinds of
reasons there could be artificial
selection
which is when we breed animals right
which is actually
how darwin that that observation helped
darwin come to the idea of natural
selection
oh interesting um and then their sexual
um meaning and the argument that that
i think his name is from makes is that
that it's the pleasure the selection
pressure is the pleasure of female birds
which as a woman and as someone who
studies affect that's a great
answer i actually think there probably
is natural i think there is an aspect of
natural selection to it which he maybe
hasn't considered
but you were saying the reason we
brought up birds is the
the life we got now seems to be quite
yeah so you
peek into the ocean peek into the sky
there are miraculous creatures
look at creatures who've gone extinct
and
you know in science fiction uh stories
you couldn't dream up something as
interesting so my guess is that
you know intelligent life evolves in
in many different ways even on this
planet there isn't one form of
intelligence there's not one brain that
gives you intelligence there are lots of
different brain structures that can give
you intelligence
so my guess is that the
menagerie might not look exactly the way
that it looks now but it would certainly
be
as as interesting
you